attendez les mecs séduire une fille à un
premier rendez vous c'est hyper facile
quand tu fais un premier rendez vous
avec une meuf t'a toujours envie que le
premier regard tout de suite soit stylet
salut salut bbc on n'a pas envie que la
première image qui allait de nous soit
une image parfaitement ridicule salut ça
va bien ramener un bouquet de fleurs un
premier rendez vous bon c'est un petit
peu romantique mais perso je trouve ça
un tout petit peu ringard et en plus on
comprend directement de ses intentions
tu vois
attends c'est pour moi les flammes tu as
cru qu'il allait se passer un truc entre
nous qu'on est plus chaud ça c'était
juste des fleurs d'amitié moi je pense
qu'il ya un truc qui doit être pas mal
pour séduire une meuf c'est de faire
comme dans les films américains
c'est de venir à chercher chez elle en
véhicule pour l'emmener sur le lieu du
rendez vous tu as ces classes encore
faut-il avoir un véhicule relativement
classique ou là ces temps dans la
voiture
non
ah c'est toi sur le scooter là à oui
c'est bon
voilà
[Musique]
j'invite sinon si tu veux moi j'ai seize
d'une ce qu est un des skate 2 places le
premier endroit où tu emmènes une fille
c'est hyper important parce que ça
montre un petit peu tes goûts ton
univers moi je sais jamais où aller pour
paraître stylet tâche dure peur que ce
soit glauque dans les yeux et demi non
c'est la première fois et je pensais que
ce serait peut-être une bonne idée
un p'tit tiercé pour un premier rendez
vous c'est pas mal de s'habiller un peu
classe un peu élégant tu vois tu chemise
cravate et veston petit slip est comme
moi je suis pas habitué à mettre des
chemises ou des vêtements classe dès que
je le fais pour un premier rencart
j'ai l'impression d'en faire des tonnes
je suis vraiment désolé je suis venu
complètement l'arraché pas le temps de
m'habiller j'ai mis n'importe quoi un
tiercé façon quand je prends un premier
verre avec une fille et qui est un petit
feeling tu sais tout de suite mais quand
il n'y a pas de feeling battu le sait
aussi
excusez moi je crois pas que ce soit une
pastèque avec des lunettes parce que moi
c'est batman c'est incroyable à moi
aussi viandes issues de bronze
c'est fou ça m'arrive rarement croisé
des gens du sud
attention parce que moi des fois quand
je suis un premier rendez vous et je
suis un peu intimidés par la fille des
fois je fais ce genre de l'écouter alors
qu en fait j'écoute même pascal dit
qu'ils allaient pour traverser comme il
était aveugle ils ont pas vu le camion
cet homme ce qu'elle n'est pas est mort
bon moi chez toi quand tu veux séduire
même le plat que tu choisisses est
important c'est tu peux pas manger un
truc nul
moi je vais prendre une choucroute xxl
avec le supplément pied de port en
entrée bas des rillettes de cervelas et
puis un pastis un billet petite cave est
gratuite si possible tu veux quoi bon
c'est bon j'ai pas faim je vais être
regarder manger en fait moi quand je
suis un premier rendez vous il est
tellement de stress tellement de
pression que des fois quand je fais une
petite pause pour à l'auto lettres deux
minutes j'ai l'impression d'être entre
deux round de match de boxe est longue
c'est bien parti ok ok pas du tout là
pour toi tu était attendu hier matin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce à la normale ouais ce cas au moment
de payer l'addition à un premier rendez
vous pour c'est plutôt le garçon bien
vite
sauf que si tu veux rester classe en
payant l'addition il faut rester assez
discret quand on regarde le prix ok ok
pour que soient classe de payer
l'addition
il faut que tu restes naturel comme si
criante avait choqué tant que malades
commence déchets rejetés par oublier
tout ça gesca vraiment qu'à ce prix là
on va rentrer chez elle et qu'elle vaut
évidemment l'idéal quand tu sors d'un
premier rendez vous avec une fille c'est
de finir un doux baiser mais moi je sais
jamais à quel moment me lancer tia
quelle seconde le faire tu vois comment
on peut se dire en toi peut-être
c'est pas un foot est à revoir
rapid un je ne sais pas quand y aller
bon j'y vais ou j'y vais pas là ce qu'il
veut vraiment que je fasse un bracelet
en or à cela embrasse la balle et je me
lance comme un homme 3 2 1 aller en bien
en fait je crois que nous les mecs
parfois on est juste un peu con c'est
tout à ça va normal ouais bof mon
premier rendez vous là c'était vraiment
un échec du coup je vais savoir style
bohème hébergés ouais bien sûr pas de
souci tiens c'est le genre d'amitié à
l'eau ouais merci d'avoir regardé ma
vidéo
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à ma
chaîne youtube à norman fait des vidéos
j'ai aussi une page facebook norman fait
des vidéos c'est toujours le même titre
toujours le même nom norman fait des
vidéos à aucun moment ça va être
kevin fait du bmx tu vois là vraiment
c'est à noter dans vos agendas et autres
et autres ipad